break down the business model of a
entrepreneur only fans content creator
so with uh only fans you can have one or
two pages you have a free page or you
have a subscription page or you have
both if you have a free page everything
you put on the wall you can charge for
if you have a subscription page you
cannot have anything for sale on your
page they pay to get in you can only
sell through the dms that's how they're
selling their videos through the dms by
hand so it does go down in the dms for
the most part okay i could never sell my
videos by hand in the dms i wake up to
hundreds of messages like it's it's
unreal i could never do that on my own
so i do that
through my freedom what are the messages
asking you or saying to you um a lot of
times how's your fish doing i mean i
haven't hey i just got to know about
your fish that's i gotta know for real
how's your new car um i have koi fish i
have like and i i put them on my insta
my socials like my community actually a
lot of it's just like did you guys have
fun at the bruins game like why do they
care that's i that's really what i want
to know and it's by the way it's the pan
social phenomenon is it pan social what
is pan pan social is when you follow
streamers or influencers and and you
know so much about them but they don't
know you so you feel like they
they feel like a friend to you because i
don't think our brains can tell the
difference but they don't know you
so it creates this weird dynamic where
you have thousands millions of people
that feel like they know you because
they're you're in their living room
right you're they're watching your
stream or on their phone or on their
phone yeah and so but you don't but but
you don't know them and so it's a it's
it's a real big phenomenon with twitch
streamers and youtubers and it it has
some
consequences to it for sure i love my
community is amazing i mean i can
literally go on there and ask like hey
i'm you know how do i put this bacteria
in this pond to keep these i mean my
they help like i just i have a great
community i have very rare i think i've
blocked five people my entire time i
mean okay i got a crazy question
because it but maybe it goes to the
connection this pan social thing you're
talking about
i'm not sure if you guys know this but
porn is free as you guys understand so
explain why someone would want to pay
12 a month or whatever i don't know what
the pricing are maybe you can elaborate
on that versus look
porn you know i'm mean i'm out except
they're not buying porn i mean they're
consuming porn but it's not about the
porn and i knew that when i signed up
like what is it about them um it's about
the connection
by the way i
fully respect what you got going on
especially because it's your husband but
they know you're married sure are there
some of them they're like maybe she'll
leave her husband for me or is it just
like i just think she's swell and i
gotta know about those koi fish
there's uh it's a connection i think
it's being able you consume porn on you
know pouring over another site you don't
ever get to talk to that girl you don't
get to no i think there's an element to
they feel like you're saying like
they're touchable yeah they're almost
touchable they can say hi they can tell
you nice video they can you know hey
just want to tell you and your husband
great let a great job last night i mean
my site does not just have adult content
i mean i do post stories of my fish or
my at the bruins game and i get just as
many likes and interaction on those as i
do my content so i do feel like it's
it's called only fans for a reason
because i think these people are truly
fans of sometimes it's all in the name
ladies and gentlemen it's called only
fans like an app rebecca as i say is
there a safety component that you
in here because just like you said this
dynamic is they feel like they know you
they they're in your living room they're
in your bedroom right
is there a safety component when you're
going out and you
you say where you are right you tell the
audience where you are
not always very good question have you
run into in public one of your fans it
happens very often but i can let people
know i nine times out of ten i have
undercover security with me they follow
they're not you don't know they're with
me but they're watching my husband it's
really they're there so my husband can
relax because
he is always scanning and what made you
say all right time for some security
something must have happened um yeah
we've had a few scares um we had a a
real actual incident of someone
threatening me and just
out of his mind and what have you and
that was very scary but when we go to
very large events um we we do have
undercover security um we do have a
massive security in our home i mean we
have 50 cameras outside our house we
have someone that monitors that so i met
your what's your husband's name again
stephen met the dude cool dude big dude
i mean i'm messing with that guy
yeah he he yeah yeah
he's uh yeah so we do have there is a
massive security yeah i would i would
completely understand like if you've got
that many fans is this when you go to
the movies and go like have dinner you
have to have security with no we don't
have security at dinner um like i
shouldn't tell them if you go to like a
convention or something any event if
we're gonna go out to a bar late at
night together and kind of just have
drinks and my husband needs to like let
relax like it kind of sucks because we
can't really have as much fun because
he's always on the lookout so it's kind
of more someone there so that like he
can kind of relax a little bit have fun
with me is that i'm assuming that's
expensive um yeah i mean it's it's yeah
it's not something you know but it's
worth it you know you're making that
paper
necessary expense i have a question
before we go to this so earlier you said
um you know only fans it's a 24 hour
seven days a week type of thing you're
always locked in and then you talked
about in terms of being nursing and how
that was 18 hours a day it it sounds
like
it sounds like you're a high performer
in whatever you do
you said you're a veteran yes thank you
for serving our country
so you come from just a high level of
output so
did did did you how much more did you
buy flexibility did you buy back time if
it's still something that's all consumed
because as creators and entrepreneurs
we're always
here thinking about the next video the
next stream i'm thinking about oh can i
put some of this on my channel how can i
chop it right i think we're always in
that mode so did you buy actual time or
did you just buy more flexibility of
your schedule more flexibility right now
but i think it's innate it's giving me
the opportunity to power through for
maybe the next three to five years and
continue like then i don't need to ever
work again i mean even right now i mean
honestly the amount of money is probably
some people's retirement plans you know
i definitely could stop working but i
think right now my mentality is hustle
hustle hustle um i say this but i have
been an overachiever for a long time and
that stems from my childhood which is a
lot of stuff that you know one day i
will dive into in some form but um yeah
i think right now it's just it's
flexibility to be able to do that but
i'm trying to build something that will
allow me to really have that time and is
it fair to say that you are an anomaly
in this world based on the fact that
when you're married to that you're a
veteran with a crazy work ethic
and three that you sound fairly
financially literate and
and probably semi-frugal that this is
not the standard this is this is the
exception to and you're a marketer yeah
so you understand the story that you're
with the nursing thing and covid like
you're telling a a very interesting
story i'm sure is helping drive people
there so is it fair to say like this is
the exception to the rule this isn't the
rule to how most people probably
experience this yeah i could honestly
say it took me a long time to accept but
i i really never
not succeeded in anything that i've done
because i just pour into
um and so i don't think this is
achievable for the average person that's
not saying there's not other girls that
are successful it only offends by any
means but i think given from where i
started ground zero as literally a
hockey mom with no follower i mean it
just for me to turn this in less than a
year and make myself into a multi it's
impressive and it took a lot for me to
like own that my husband has to say it
all the time like you have to look
around like
look what the heck has happened over the
past year and a lot of people think the
press that i was interviewed on
everywhere um is what really turned me
into this
i got the press because i had already
did that because you're already booming
yeah and how did they know you were
making this much money did you tell them
that so
i'm talking the press the original story
that went out with the daily beast um i
did an interview um and i actually was
just interviewing he was like you're a
nurse and you're doing only fans well as
i started to say well actually i'm not
nursing because i just got let go from
my job because of xyz and that's where
the story is like oh my god like this is
the story you literally were like oh and
that's where things boomed up but yes in
that interview you know he asked and i
had to show you know that i was truly
making that kind of money at that point
i think i was making seventy five eighty
thousand dollars a month is what the
original that's what you were making a
year
as a nurse
see this is my theory and you guys push
back this is my this is my theory my
theory is
you would have figured out content
regardless exactly i think you would
have figured out if it would have came
slower but the numbers you're providing
they're they're big numbers what do you
mean figured out content how to monetize
she she would be a booming youtuber oh
yeah
right and so like it would have came
slower because again
lust of the eyes less than the flesh
right what's the easy commodity to tie
in but
me kevin's making three four hundred
grand a month on youtube you know he was
doing this at like 500 000 subscribers
so i know creators that make that money
on youtube and again exception to the
rule but when you have your skill set
your story and the work ethic i think
you would have figured it out it just
would have came slower for you
yeah i was already doing side stuff like
i was building you're probably familiar
with poshmark
i was buying and selling used goods and
building this poshmark and within the
first four months i had already made
like 40 grand like i was i just
everything i do if i pour in i could
just i always suggest
yeah let's look at some of these numbers
yeah i say that because i don't want if
there's girls watching this to hear this
story and be like i'm gonna make 200k
exactly well let's get into these
numbers all right so here's some only
fans
stats okay so here's some key statistics
more than 170 million people use only
fans okay
500 000 new users join every day
jesus
there are more than 1.2 million content
creators we have one right here one of
the exceptional ones it's possible with
more than two million dollars a month
from only fans that's the top top top
top top top point one percent uh on
average
uh only fans creators make around a
hundred grand a month say that again
they only the top creators that's the
top creators okay
the average creator makes around 151 a
month
that's what you want the people to know
the average
only fans creator makes 151 a month
whereas the top makes almost 100 grand a
month interesting
the average only fans creator has 21
subscribers another weren't weren't the
average only fan subscription is seven
dollars 20 cents only fans has paid out
more than two
billion to creators i want to find out
who's gonna be the first
billionaire only fans content creator uh
for some uh
for some numbers so you understand
growth
only fan started in 2019 it's only three
years old
i gotta get an only fans account
2019 at 7 million subscribers since then
it's gone from 12 to 30 to 75 million in
2020 in 2021 it hit 120 million
currently
uh that was september so this is old
this is september of 2021 it's got
probably over 250 million subscribers at
this point is what i'm saying okay
extrapolating current growth here go
down a little bit uh the other way sorry
natalia the other way back up boom nope
nope back all right
keep going the grass yep
uh no no right above the graph
okay the world pandemic okay
by extrapolating the current growth rate
google search trends and their own
research we approximate they're
currently a half a new new millions
joint everyday or we got that it's
basically exploded okay yeah um let's
look at these numbers
how many creators are on only fans as of
2019 100 000
by the beginning of 2021 we're talking
1.2 million now there's over i assume 2
million how much do only fans make this
is what we wanted to understand ruslan
scroll down a little bit
what is the average only fans income and
earnings the average
creator will make 151
a month keep going most creators lose
money how do you lose money i would
imagine like purchasing equipment things
like you know
outfits outfits etc and you're not if
you're not making enough to put back i
mean go buy a 300
lingerie yeah
um we've all been the top only fans
creator is currently bell delphine who
charges 35 a month what do you know
about her
i've actually never heard of okay well
maybe you should subscribe a lot of
girls that will shock you you don't
you've never heard of them but they're
killing how many subscribers does the
average only fans
content creator have the only fans the
average has 21 subscribers got it
all right keep scrolling down
all right so the point is this
it's very hard to make money and only
fans if you're the average content
creator you're making
150 bucks a month yeah there's no
discovery feature i think that's what a
lot of people don't realize you have to
give it up for these girls that that do
drive the traffic there because you
can't promote it on your instagram you
can't promote it anywhere pretty much
and there's no discovery feature so
you're doing all your own marketing and
driving your own traffic there um which
obviously you hit roadblocks along every
way because you're trying to drive
someone to adult content so it's
um it's a lot of work that goes behind
it and you're right the average person
doesn't have the time especially if it's
a side gig and or the energy to be able
to do okay so if you like that clip
click right here to watch another or if
you want to watch the entire sauscast
click right here
[Music]